مشاهدينا ننوه لهذا الخبر العاجل عن وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه اصابه 13 شخص حالات
بعضهم خطره باطلاق النار في منطقه النبي
يعقوب الشمالي القدس بطبيعه الحال سنعود
الى هذا الخبر بتفاصيل اكثر ساعيد وانوه
لهذا الخبر العاجل اذا وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اصابه 13 شخص حالات
بعضهم خطره وذلك باطلاق نار في منطقه
النبي يعقوب شمالي القدس ومشاهدين هذه
الصور اوليه لمكان وقوع هذه العمليه عمليه
اطلاق نار مثل ما قلنا في منطقه النبي
يعقوب شمالي القدس
و بحسب مصادر محليه هناك
استنفار امني وهذه الصور مثل ما قلنا وردت
الينا قبل قليل لمكان وقوع عمليه اطلاق
النار طبعا في انتظار المزيد من التفاصيل
من عين المكان سنعود الى هذا الموضوع
ينضم او نعود الان لمشاهده هذه الصور التي
وردت الينا قبل قليل من القدس